foreign
starts this hour in Dallas Texas hey
Cindy how are you
my situation is I am 61 years old I'm in
a job I've been with this company for 12
years I want to change jobs
um if I I need to work with people that
care about their job that come to their
work and do the work and know what
they're expected to do and do it
um my Instagram that you talked about
I'm a moral perfectionist loyal guardian
and I also did Ken Coleman's
assessment I'm my talent is inspection
instruction execution my passion is
leading finishing analyzing and my
mission is achievement I want to change
jobs but my friends and family are
telling me I should not because of my
age I need to stay put because it's
going to be hard for me to find a job
and I have applied for jobs and I don't
even get an interview now when I used to
get lots of interviews I mean I have
Stellar work history and
I just been stuck I don't know what to
do okay so before we get into uh the
applying process and what frustrating
results you're dealing with there I'm
just curious I heard some things on you
that I've heard before and I'm just
curious what you would say is the number
one and maybe two reasons why you want
to leave this company
give me the quick version
okay
um because
the people they're
um I mean they don't come to work and
it's an office it's a professional sure
business
um I mean they they call in I mean they
don't want to work I mean they sleep at
their desk all right let me ask you this
I'm a worker I know I can tell are you
leading those people or are these
co-workers well they were co-workers but
our manager left they moved me into the
management position and I asked to be
moved back because I I just couldn't I
mean I want people to Sure know what
their job is do their job be able to do
their job
do your job I get it now let's just
remember back and I'm not in management
anymore got it okay now let's remove
that frustration from our conversation
just for a moment let's just put it over
to the side
do you love what you're doing do you
like what you're doing forget the
frustration my work and I love our
clients all right so a couple of things
I want you to consider I'm not in any
way telling you not to look elsewhere
however
your Enneagram that you shared with us
is really at the source your wiring is
at the source of your frustration that
moralist and what's happening I know I
know and I get it and I want to try to
set you free from it because you had the
opportunity to do something about it
when you were in management but you
walked away from them not getting on you
about it not judging you but you you had
as a manager theoretically if you had
supportive support above you to Fire and
get rid of some of those people or to
Mentor them and and see what motivates
them you had your chance there but now
that you're back if you want to stay
where you are because you love the work
and you're 61 and you're having a hard
time looking out you know and seeing
other opportunities you've got to get to
the point where you go I'm responsible
for my work and I am their co-worker not
their mom I am their co-worker not their
aunt I am their co-worker not their
leader and you've got to decide because
what I'm hearing from here judge jury
and execution that's right it's not your
call and so the source of all of your
tension and frustration is you looking
at everybody else sloughing off slacking
I get it
I get it I get the frustration it
affects it affects my work only okay all
right that was my next question how much
is it affecting your ability to do your
job now this is the question not how
much is it affecting your ability to
focus on your job because I think you're
focused on them and giving them too much
power
but how much is it affecting your
ability see that's what the giggle is
how much is it affecting your ability to
actually execute on your work
10 percent
um
maybe 10. I I don't know it's just when
there's errors made I'm the one that has
to deal with our customers
okay have you taken this to your leader
to say hey I'm crushing it but I'm
having to deal with it they're afraid
they don't want to lose anybody because
we've already had a lot of people leave
and that's what's going on right now we
have a lot of leaders right now that are
afraid to fire anybody because of this
big gap we have those aren't leaders
those are whistles that's exactly right
you can't control that so what you have
to decide here is wait a second what is
best for me Cindy
because if I love my work can I at the
age of 61 with a lot of maturity and a
lot of work ethic can I allow this stuff
to bounce off of me or is it no longer
tenable I can't do this any longer
that's what I really want to know I
think you go get a new job I think so
too but I also don't fly so walk her
through walk her through the application
well I wanted to challenge you because I
I don't think it's as bad as you're
making it out to be but here's the thing
if you got to get noticed in today's
world it's not by applying online
because even small businesses are using
softwares and and they're weeding people
out you're 61 which means you have at
least four Decades of relationships and
connections and you have got to shake
the tree you got to get out there and go
hey I'm looking to move on here's
specifically what I'm looking for and it
is relationships that will get you in
the door because they go let me tell you
about Cindy Cindy's amazing but if you
just apply and some people may see your
age they may not but you may not even
get your resume looked at so this is all
about the proximity principle I wrote
about book that details this in great
detail I'll give it to you we'll put you
we'll give it to you when we put you on
hold but this is about you leveraging
your relationship Capital do you
understand what I'm saying yeah yeah I I
think you have a distinct Marketplace
Advantage because you actually know how
to work and you're mature no question
you're actually not a work yeah I mean
we've got a whole group of people out
there that honestly somebody just needs
to shut their butt on fire
I mean really seriously I just freaking
lazy quiet quitting will get you nothing
I'm telling you man if you NE if you aim
at mediocrity and you think uh playing
Call of Duty four hours a day while you
call it while you're supposed to be
doing work from home is a good idea
you're you're going to be nothing in
your life and you're going to deserve
every bit of that yeah so you know we if
you have the ability to to light
yourself on fire to get up leave the
cave kill something drag it home you
want to be somebody you want to be great
you want some greatness in your life you
want to throw your shoulders back and
Howl at the Moon and cause some stuff to
happen like Cindy does you are an
absolute rock star in America today
that's right I mean if you actually what
she's saying is the bar is so freaking
low if you show up at work and work
while you're at work you stand out
I mean that's how easy it is out there
right now in the land of stupid
just show up at work and work while
you're at work
aim at some greatness be somebody Cindy
I think you need to get a new job I
think you work with doofuses